hey what's up brandon and theo
and the gang i got a king it or sting it
for you
[Music]
the mcdonald's mcrib you know all that
all that juicy right there yeah that
sauce is popping
up you get them i want to see how y'all
feel about it because here in kentucky
we like to beat that meat up oh gang
gang
i'ma let you in on a little secret
homeboy that ain't meat play but i know
right that ain't meat
when they gotta form it into the in the
so it looks like
ribs from a [ __ ] animal wouldn't it
count as a patty
it's very it's a pat it's like a weird
patty that's in a [ __ ]
shape of a rib i still eat it well when
i was a kid i just eat the [ __ ] on them
that's why i'm fat now
oh okay yeah everything my dad would
wake me up
it's mcrib month we'd go there damn
every day yeah i get a nice vanilla
shake a mcrib a large fry
finish it off with an apple pie son you
know what i'm talking about no exactly
what you're talking about you get the
onions on there the pickles
then you get older realize that ain't
meat baby
[Music]
i like the asian version of that a
mcshort rib
but real like short rib like that's who
knows that's like cow nose we don't know
what the [ __ ] it is
no pun intended a mcrib well it's here
it's gone it's here it's gone
you know it's like it's almost like it's
almost like
the chappelle's dad of sandwiches
[Laughter]
i'm sitting here all interesting i
wonder what i'm sorry
i'm just joking it shows up it's great
it leads breaks your heart it comes back
i'm coming to get you i swear
but those couple days when it's here
when it's mcrib month it's a fun time
and if the mcrib had to be out there
every time while it was going taking
care of [ __ ] man
yeah you never know what mcrib went
through yeah you have to handle business
yeah they go away and [ __ ] i don't know
you got to hold it down man it's tough
sometimes you know
we don't know what mcgrib's doing when
it's gone we don't know the tough times
that it
you know we don't know what it has to
deal with we just get to have the joy
while it's here you know
yeah yeah enjoy it while it's here you
know yeah do you eat them do you eat
them theo
i don't eat make ribs man i don't uh
i feel like it there's always been
something about it that's gone the wrong
way for me
mcdonald's in general i'll do two
cheeseburgers and that's what i do you
know that's what i do now
growing up we didn't even my mama didn't
take us to mcdonald's but uh they had a
man
across a street named mr willie and he
would take us over there and he had a
nice truck and we'd get in the truck and
he had a son i knew his son
and he'd take us over there and get a
happy meal [ __ ]
was mr willy his actual name or like a
nickname you guys know
what was that mr willy was his actual
[Laughter]
what do we got there nick what's his
intel uh 67 percent of people sting
the mcrae yeah really they're frowned
upon it's literally
they're disgusting it's losing its
allure yeah well it's tough to compete
with chick-fil-a man
yeah yeah i heard mcdonald's are
starting to put uh tell you what
is in their food now like you know like
with cigarettes and you believe them
no i'm saying like the unhealthy [ __ ]
yeah that's what i heard because them
chicken
mcnuggets are deep-fried snot those
things are disgusting
oh you don't like the chicken nuggets
why would i get mcdonald's what
uh just like theo i just get the regular
burger two
uh cheeseburgers ketchup only
[Music]